[Music]  um  you saw the monuments the gates of morai  are opened by water  the answer must be hidden in the  shaman's ancestral knowledge passed down  through generation please ah  yes  i remember that  i thought it had to do with the ritual  for rain  please go to the meeting area  [Music]  please  listen to judea's voice  dear gods  please  watch over the descendants of enchavia  is  [Applause]  hmm  you nomads don't know who you're messing  with there is no escape  [Laughter]  my new pet hasn't eaten in days  it's starving  destroy them  [Applause]  stupid worm  [Music]  at least none of the other bandits saw  that  [Music]  uh  uh  ah  goodness  this creature is tainted with evil  i'll take care of it  ah  i'm glad the damage is minimal  this must have broken their spirits too  [Music]